BUKOLA AYODELE: Today, we're
talking about Google Cloud
Next.
I'm Bakula, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Google Cloud Next just happened
and it was quite an event.
Hundreds of speakers
came from Google Cloud,
and our partners came together
to talk about everything
from Anthos to Zero Trust.
Don't worry if you didn't
get a chance to see it live.
We have all the Talks
interactive sessions available,
so you can catch up on all
the exciting announcements.
Here's a few of our favorites.
Developing the Cloud
should help you
unlock new ways to work
without locking you in.
There is no shortage of
conversation around Anthos,
and there's plenty
of new features
to help you take advantage
of all that Cloud offers.
Anthos for virtual machines lets
you standardize on Kubernetes,
even with virtual
machine workloads.
And the Anthos
Multi-Cloud API will
make it easier to manage GKE
clusters running on other Cloud
providers.
Good security comes from more
than just the tools available.
It's about the knowledge
and best practices.
The Google Cloud
Cybersecurity Action Team
gathers experts
from across Google
to guide you through
security transformations
and to make your business safer.
Of course, we also have tools
like data loss prevention built
into BigQuery to
identify sensitive data,
and expanding Security
Command Center
with Chronicle integration.
Dealing with the data
can also be a challenge.
Driving business
value can be difficult
if your teams are blocked on
how to collect or analyze data.
Vertex AI is a
centralized solution
with integration across data
PROC, BigQuery, Dataplex,
and Looker.
Vertex AI Workbench offers
a unified user experience
for building and
deploying ML models.
And serverless Spark
on Google Cloud
lets you focus on
what matters most
to your applications
and your data.
Of course, we can't
have the Cloud
without protecting the Earth.
That's why we're
excited to announce
that Google is committing to
running on carbon-free energy
by 2030.
We're also launching
Carbon Footprint,
which helps you measure,
track, and report
on your sustainability goals.
Active Assist is also being
updated with information
on carbon impact
for recommendations,
and Earth Engine is
coming to Google Cloud
to bring you geospatial
data at scale.
Wow, that's a lot
of announcements.
If you want to read
more or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.